three significant different
organizations at the other university
have come together to create any lecture
series this semester
focusing on climate and history the
organization's of the yealt climate and
energy institute the elders supervisor
of studies and the newly constituted
yell climate and history initiative
organized by faculty and a variety of
departments and our intention with this
is to each by distinguished climate
ecologist
Fela primatologists and climate
historians for this semester and our
first naturally enough was the decision
to bring bill Ruddiman here to speak
before us about his work on the early
epigenetic hypothesis mister Ruddiman
is never tired from the University of
Virginia he started out in his PhD at
Columbia University been working for the
United States Navy's oceanographic
research department and and working as a
research scientist at Columbia Vermont
and finally working as a professor at
the University of Virginia School of
Environmental Studies over that period
of time his contributions are extremely
significant particularly his work on
tectonic uplift in tibet with hoods back
and his former student Maureen Remo and
the origins of the East Asian monsoon
and then beginning in 2003 publications
concerning his discovery his realization
his early and the organic hypothesis
which had mercy
great deal of attention over the past
more than one decade more recently is in
the recipient of the award of the
Society and I had a very full day and
one of these people has a kind of a
mushy voice and if I'm in a crowded room
I'm I'm kind of up at the top of my
range trying to be heard and I've woken
up the second day with virtually no
voice before so you're lucky I've still
still got a voice in fact it's down in a
far more impressive register than I
usually speak we could speak from can
you hear me back there I assume you can
I once flew out to Illinois to give a
talk to the atmospheric sciences
department and on the way out I caught a
cold
I had a couple lay overs and long stops
and I visited faculty the next morning
and I was losing my voice and losing my
voice and four o'clock came to give the
lecture I didn't have any voice left at
all and I said could you crank up the
amplitude on this microphone
I said I'm giving this lecture and I
whispered a 50-minute lecture I said I
swear I didn't say one word that was so
you're lucky today this hypothesis that
Harvey mentioned it's kind of a
interesting situation most of you I
gather would be scientists and you you
know that hypotheses come and go some of
them are just ignored from the beginning
some of them get a little attention are
shot down completely and then they're
ignored some of them succeed and become
theories I see some smiles out there
this is a personal experience
as I guess and but this one is in a
middle category which is the hypothesis
from the beginning had enough evidence
that you just couldn't say it was
impossible and it's it made it made
pretty good sense but there were there
was other evidence that argued against
it and I'm gonna try and touch on both
of those and if I skim over the
criticisms of the hypothesis forget to
get into that you can bring me back so
but I would describe the situation is
that community is like this you talk to
different people you talk to different
disciplines you talk to different
universities and you meet people that
don't like the idea and you didn't meet
people that think it's obviously correct
and so it's hanging out there I'm very
optimistic that I'll live to see it
become a new paradigm but it's not there
yet
so I have two kinds of evidence the way
that talk is structured two kinds of
evidence that bear on the hypothesis
that was this maybe I'll save my voice a
little more so one line of evidence for
those of you either heard me yesterday
there'll be some repetition from
yesterday's talk but much more depth
here one is top-down evidence of these
early anthropogenic changes that is to
say that farmers in agriculture were all
altering climate thousands of years ago
it didn't all start with the industrial
era greenhouse gas increases that began
really noticeably around 1850 and this
this top-down evidence has to do with
the composition of the of the atmosphere
particularly carbon dioxide and methane
and the way that this evidence comes
into play is that people that have
drilled down through ice cores and
retrieved dome see Antarctica retrieved
800,000 year record of past greenhouse
guests
positions that record goes through
several more than a half dozen previous
interglacials and those are times when
nobody's claiming that humans were
massively affecting greenhouse gases so
there that's a time when greenhouse gas
changes were natural and there I'm gonna
show you results from seven of them so
we can take the Holocene which has its
own carbon dioxide and methane trends
and which I say is over printed by
humans and compared against these
experiments that Nature has run in the
previous interglacials here are records
from previous interglacial of methane at
the top carbon dioxide at the bottom in
there they're all they're all aligned on
a common reference point in the ice core
Tom timescale which is set to the
present day which happens to be a time
when one of the orbital elements
precession is at a sign Omega is at a
maximum value but you could think of it
Northern Hemisphere summer insulation is
at a minimum so these these all have a
common alignment within the errors of
the time scale so it's not it's not
perfect astronomically from the orbital
their orbital elements it's perfect but
when you try to apply that the
astronomical changes to the dating of
the ice core it's not perfect now you
you should be able to see here that I've
left my pointer I'll just walk over that
oh okay that's better
there is something of a common pattern
you may be able to proceed in both these
trends and it's similar it's more
dramatic in there methane there are low
values at times comparable to 15,000
years ago that's late in the D
glaciations that precede these inter
glaciations there's rise to peaks
somewhere in this interval and in most
cases there are decreases this is
methane to lower values and those
decreases go on straight through the
time of the present but plotted in red
is the Holocene which has a similar peak
I'm not going to talk about this feature
which is the Younger Dryas which is a
different climatic beast altogether but
the methane trend also reaches a peak in
the same general area comes down and
then it goes goes back up your eye might
catch these two high points that's a
that's a interglacial stage 19 which is
almost 800,000 years ago and it looks
like it's following the methane but
that's that's a brief Peak recognized
from the beginning as being again one of
these brief changes if this if I extend
this time scale for stage 19 a methane
trend went down so they all go down
except for the Holocene as far as
methane is concerned and that thing goes
way up instead of down and so that was
the first indication I didn't have all
this data but ten years ago but that was
an indication something's different
and for methane it starts at 5,000 years
ago
co2 at least plotted at this scale is
much more muted basically the same
pattern lower values in here in this
case the lower values are a little bit
off to this direction Peaks usually I
think always in the same exact sample as
the methane Peaks so methane and co2
reach a peak
and then most of these trends go
downward some don't go down very much
but oh but carbon dioxide in the
Holocene goes up starts down and then
goes up so it's anomalous
there is one interglacial I'll point out
stage 15 which doesn't have this rapid
rise it it doesn't have a look of a
deglaciation and instead other
indicators indicate that the glaciation
is somehow going on through the inter
glaciation so whether you would even
call it an inter glaciation is
questionable but that's a lot of
information for your Ida to take in so a
few years ago I thought let's lump all
those previous interglacials together
and you compute the same kind of
timescale relevant to the Holocene so
you could lock lock your time thinking
into the Holocene so there's this is the
average of seven previous interglacials
and this is the standard deviation you
remember some of those some of those
curves will come up higher and kind of
drift down lower some came up not as far
and drifted lower so most of the
scatterers due to that so that methane
like some other interglacials a little
bit higher than the stacked average
although it's within the standard
deviation comes down comes down faster
than the stacked average till five
thousand years ago and I think I make
the claim that downward is natural
because that's what always happened on
previous interglacials so very
dramatically five thousand years ago
methane takes off and by the last two
thousand years it's outside the envelope
of variation of the previous
interglacials co2 it's the same story
now this is amazing overlap here but
individual co2 trends almost inter
glaciation some of them are up in here
and then
now some of them are only up to here and
come down so it's more typical I would
say this is maybe the more typical case
but it's the same thing its co2 is close
to the average way in this case well
within the standard deviation and around
6500 years ago 7000 years ago you get
this what I call wrong-way trend both of
these are wrong way trends so if one
thing so if if if downward is natural I
mean the whole first part of my
hypothesis is if downward is natural
these are not natural and not natural is
my mind equivalent to an anthropogenic
yes oh yeah this is pretty
pre-industrial looks like it goes to
zero but it goes actually goes to may
teen not actually not quite I think 1800
in this case see methane gets up in here
just before the industrial era co2 is
about in this range just before
industrial times so downward is natural
upward is not natural now one of those
inter glaciations stage 19 I pointed out
the method that anomalous methane pump
let me back up early in the evaluation
on hypothesis one of the major
criticisms was that people started
looking for individual analogues what's
the best analog for the Holocene in
terms of insulation and the one that was
put forward forward with stage in 11 and
the reason it was put forward you can
see here the red and the black are very
similar in amplitude some of these other
interglacials that the amplitude of the
precession effect gets much higher and
gets much lower but these are very close
in amplitude
people said well that's the best
analogue that was back when the ice
cores only got back to about 400,000
years subsequently they go back to
800,000 years and that brings into play
stage 19 just before just after 800,000
years ago and it also has an amplitude
that's very very close just as close at
least to the whole asinus stage 11 so
now you have the two possibilities for
analogs but this early criticism was all
focused on precession and ignored
obliquity and all the science I'm aware
of says you can't ignore obliquity and
things like growth and decay of ice
sheets you've got to consider both of
them and so look what happens with
obliquity stage 11 these are aligned
relative to these time skills but also
relative to each other if you align
stage 1 and 11 like this then obliquity
has a maximum way over here and in stage
19 and much later in stage 11 so stage
11 is not a good insulation analog
stage 19 in contrast has its maximum at
the same relative position it's lower in
amplitude so that's the one shortfall of
using that as an analogue there is no
perfect analog but it's much better to
have some amplitude mismatch than to
have a complete offset of relative
timing so stage 19 is now accepted among
people who are paying attention to the
problem that as the best orbital
insulation analog now that's interesting
because you could go to the ice core and
co2 is most important greenhouse gas in
terms of anthropogenic impacts on the
atmosphere here's that stage 1
high-resolution trend again you've seen
it before
here's stage 19 much lower resolution so
it's not capturing the full signal peaks
are very similar downward trend this one
goes down faster
here's that reversal in the Holocene but
look what the what stage nineteen is
doing it could it continues down and it
ends up at a point around two hundred
and forty five parts per million or less
whereas in the whole scene it's 280 or
more now with the original hypothesis
and not having all this density at data
I projected or I estimated that the
value in the in the Holocene today that
is we'd be between 240 and 245 so I
projected that kind of a value and I'm
feeling pretty good about that estimate
right now so so a natural experiment
that Nature has run gives you the co2
value that the early and thorough genic
hypothesis would suggest now if you take
if you take this is for stage 19 if you
take the observed obliquity value
precession value and co2 value and the
methane value and not a climate model
experiment it obviously gives you a
colder earth it's not much difference up
here but 40 parts per million of co2 is
a big difference that's half the glacial
interglacial signal almost so it gives
you a much colder earth and on that
colder earth and the kinds of models
that full general circulation models you
can't run a ice sheet a couple of ice
sheet because it's to the MA the model
has such complexity it can only run for
decades unless you have a lot of money
so but what it can tell you is what are
the areas where the snow cover doesn't
ever melt in the summer and by
definition if you get through the summer
and
into September with snow on the ground
it's gonna get added to the next year
and the next year in the next year so
those are areas that my co-authors John
cuts buck that Harvey men mentioned and
I say our areas of incipient glaciation
those are areas that should get a nice
sheet of some size and thickness if the
model could run long enough big chunk of
northern northeastern Siberia and
northern Canadian Rockies Brooks Range
the Canadian archipelago Baffin Island
just to give you some scale Baffin
Island is about size of California and
Oregon put together Oregon sorry so
those areas would all be going under
glaciation of course Greenland's already
there so it's just going to get a little
more placing agent so so stage 19 is
telling us that there should be a small
glaciation underway which is also a part
of the original early anthropogenic
hypothesis along that same line of
thinking here is that's a repeat of
stage 9 yeah let's see this is the
repeat of what I just showed you it's
hard to tell them apart and this is this
is a run a simulation for the projected
greenhouse gas values according to the
early anthropogenic hypothesis there's
almost no difference so stage 19 is is
the nature's test run of the early
anthropogenic hypothesis I think the
biggest differences I recall a little a
little bit in the Alaska Canadian
Rockies a little more a little more snow
cover up here but I don't have to worry
about
so the looks like the earth would be
glaciated in these areas not big ice
sheets down in Chicago or anything like
that just
small or medium-sized Greenland sized
ice sheets or ice cover starting to
thicken that and that's really upset
people because it just sounds so
unlikely we would actually be in a
natural glaciation but there's a there's
a way to look at it makes it makes it
sound pretty reasonable here is let's
see which one should i do first okay
this plot shows caloric summer solar
insolation which is the in the northern
hemisphere that's the one Milankovitch
used in his theory back in 1941 and
here's the range of values from maximum
to minimum insulation over the last half
million years so cycles don't always go
to the full maximum full minimum some of
them are smaller but that's the full
range here's the value the actual value
ten thousand eleven thousand years ago
here's the current value so you're
almost exactly halfway to a full civil
lowest extreme of the insulation and
that's certainly a push a plausible push
towards glaciation here's the co2 value
you could kind of ignore the methane
value because it's it's forcing a
climate is much smaller but it adds to
the story here's the variation of co2
over the last half million years
interglacial glacial and here's that
downward chin and that projection that I
mentioned earlier you end up cap if you
count in the methane you end up about
half way again so you're you're more
you're halfway towards the lowest values
that push the fastest growth of glaciers
so it's it's not surprising that you
could be getting the beginning of
glaciation if you look at it that way
you wanted us to focus on this bathroom
I don't think for just because it's for
scale but that wasn't that thought to be
the seed of the Laurentide ice sheet I
mean what idea was it depending leisure
there on monthly on Baffin Island was
deceived for the for the long time I bet
is that important to your argument or
not really but there are different
arguments that's again that's Baffin
there are some there there's a number of
hypotheses go back 40 years now I think
that do talk about that the Laurentide
comes out of this this region some of
them put it on Baffin some of them put
it even in northern Labrador some of
them put it up towards the archipelago
so that's that's what we're that's a
part of the literature that's not
inconsistent with what I'm saying but
I'm not stressing it or leaning on it or
I don't need that from my arguments
northern Siberia in some of the early
reconstructions of where where the ice
sheets had been had been didn't have as
large an ice sheet that's where the
mammoths were we're stuck in Rangel
eafford yes that's correct
al and ice sheet the in that in that
area there's an arranged shadow of death
Amalia the evidence from a number of
studies over the last few decades is
that at the last glacial maximum there's
no massive ice sheet in Siberia there's
a number of smaller ones scattered in
through there but there's no massive ice
sheet but by the time in the last
glacial maximum Siberia is much drier
than it is in the early growth phases
and there's there's scattered evidence
for instance along the coast of Africa
and all along the width of a Siberia and
the coast of Alaska they're scattered
evidence for new ice sheets draining
into the ocean so there was almost
certainly more more snow and
there have been people who have said
there were larger ice sheets still not
Laurentide sized but larger ice sheets
early because it's there's air you know
air masses with more moisture or making
the trip from the Atlantic or from the
South so it's not it's it's not a it's
not a misprediction unless you think
it's means that that that's going to
grow up to be a continuous ice sheet at
20,000 and it didn't and the regent
region the reason would appear to be
that it got starved for moisture and
that's been in the literature for a
while okay oh yeah this this I just
recently compiled this is from the lucky
Remo stack of oxygen isotopic values
from the Atlantic and the Pacific deep
ocean and I thought well I should do the
same kind of thing that I did for the
for the the greenhouse gases and it's a
little different in that that the the
way this time scale is tuned it's it's
it's it's tuned under the assumption
that the Oh 18 record which is a record
of mostly ice by him but also
temperature lags behind the insulation
forcing so what these curves do is they
give you D glaciations up till about the
equivalent of about six thousand years
ago on average and then they you see
that most of them start to turn around
at some point in that sequence again the
whole scene looks different it doesn't
turn around
and again stage 15 looks different it
just keeps rising and it's still rising
at the end of the record that was the
one that gave you that anomalous co2
plot so we'll talk about that later but
so there's a similarity in these trends
and most of them are not like the
Holocene and if you do that same
stacking exercise you get a
pattern that looks like that here's the
6000 years ago ice volume temperature
minimum the most interglacial climate
state and then the average is going
steadily towards a more glacial state
for the last six thousand years Holocene
is running along looking like like that
until somewhere in about here and then
takes off in the ocean we don't think
there's any major melting of ice sheets
going on here to drive that curve upward
so it would seem to be a warming of the
year of the deep ocean so that's just
when the co2 curve starts to depart from
normal and co2 curve if it were if it
warms the atmosphere because it keeps
rising and that's anomalous it'll warm
the deep ocean as well so that that is
consistent with the greenhouse gas
information yeah
let's see
oh no the next one sorry
forward thank you same just to please
remind me what the that's the chronology
when people think the Laurentide Ice
Sheet collapsed as well as the Scandia
okay no velorek Laurentide ice sheet I I
won't use the word collapse but it it
started melting 17,000 years ago and
there's plenty of glacial geological
evidence that the last little remnants
of it melted between seven and six
thousand years it's just a tiny little
fragment up and up in the Labrador so it
would be in about here
which is right right close to the other
curves reaching their minimum ice extent
so just to say that there's something
anomalous about the oxygen isotope curve
in the Holocene and it's anomalous in
much the same way as the greenhouse
gases and its anomalous at a time that
the greenhouse gases could be
contributing to it okay so that's the
first body of evidence I would make a
claim and I don't convinced it everybody
but if the Holocene is that anomalous if
it's if down as natural and up is not
natural and what can you think of as not
natural well it's humans I think this is
powerful evidence I don't see how people
can argue against it but it doesn't it
doesn't convince everyone so that that's
one reason the hypothesis is still
lingering the other kind of evidence
which I called bottom-up because at the
time that the greenhouse gases are
behaving anomalously humans are coming
up with best domesticated crops and
animals these numbers and white are in
thousands of years ago and they mark the
time when domestication which had
already occurred begins to spread him so
9,000 years ago in northern China 9,000
years ago in the Fertile Crescent the
original domestication goes back
farther 5,000 years ago for rice out of
central [ __ ] south central China 5,000
to 4,000 years ago in Africa 4,000 years
ago in Mexico and Peru so the whole time
that these anomalies are getting
stronger agriculture is spreading and
agriculture can affect both methane and
co2 so I'll start with methane and say
remind you that it's 5,000 years ago
that the that the methane trend goes the
wrong way this is a compilation that
just came out - three years ago two
years ago no three years ago durian for
University College London all the red
dots are data points carbon-14 they
dated data points showing the first
arrival of irrigated rice into all this
area of southern Asia and the reason
irrigated rice is important is that the
rice paddies are basically swamps you
can't think of them as human-made swamps
and in a rice in the rice paddies the
water the waters not circulating it's
just sitting there and it's keeping the
right the feet of the rice in the water
so that it'll grow fast and methane as
there's enough carbon in the patties
that it take it strips the oxygen oxygen
out of the water and what comes out
after that is methane which is the same
thing you get if you're looking at a
stagnant pool or pond or swamp think we
would call it swamp gas at least in some
parts of the country so this is a the
spread of manmade swamp gas producing
methane across across all of of southern
Asia starts around 5,000 years ago in
the right Yangtze River Valley where the
domestication occurred and by a thousand
years ago it's basically spread
everywhere that it's going to spread or
where it's farm today so if Dorian
fuller took these times of first arrival
of rice irrigated rice into these areas
and then applied a model in which he
assumed that that the rice growing would
densify always have trouble finding
order we'd get it would cover the
landscape progressively from just a few
rice paddies to sprawl to the modern
sprawl yeah of rice paddies and he came
up with a plot of the time the trail
upward trend in rice irrigated rice
farming as a percentage of the modern
value value from there's nothing at six
thousand years ago a little bit at five
thousand and mind you that's just one
the methane trend starts to go the wrong
way and he from that he calculated using
the methane using the irrigated rice
area and using modern relationships
between irrigated rice area methane
emissions and methane concentrations in
the atmosphere he constant he calculated
a methane curve doing that over the time
between 5,000 and 1,000 years ago and
here's what the ice quirk says that it
did so he calculated 70 parts per
billion the actual concentration rose
100 so the rice irrigation is explaining
a good chunk of this rise but there is a
added factor you remember the natural
trend of methane was something like this
it was going down all the way from
10,000 years ago straight through to
today so so though the methane anomaly
is not just the increase it's the fact
that it didn't decrease the way it
should have so you have to have fact
factor that in so this 70 parts per
billion
is less a smaller fraction of the
observed hundred parts per billion than
you might think there was a question of
no pause in a minute and take it
fuller also mapped the spread of
livestock across the continents for this
interval seven to five thousand five to
three three to one and if you go back
seven to five thousand years ago there
are livestock in Africa in the Sahara
where the valleys are in many cases
grasslands because the monsoon is
running much more strong and a little
bit an Iranian plateau and some in
western China which is a a very arid
region these are not forested areas they
were not and they are not but so there's
cattle and other livestock but there the
land is a low carrying capacity so it's
not probably that it's probably not that
many livestock by five thousand to three
thousand years ago you're you're getting
into Indian China in areas which are
naturally forested so if you've got
livestock people have to clear the
forest to get to a lot livestock to feed
and the carrying capacity in these
wetter areas is much higher so once
livestock gets in there they can they
can there can be high density on the
land so livestock spreads down into
India over the eastern China and all the
way down through down into Africa by
three thousand two one thousand years
ago so this map shows you that methane
extra methane is being generated here
here here and also in in Europe where
people are just get got getting into
which I'll show you in a minute so
yet the calculations you so can I assume
that account was take another lifetime
than methane and they have experienced
really short it's very short time yeah
it's so it's so short that it's pretty
close to if you got an acre a hectare of
rice paddy you've got a certain amount
of methane coming off and it's going to
sustain a certain amount of methane and
that in the atmosphere it so it's
completely by analogy with the modern
modern relationship plus it that imp
well the yep yeah that those
observations implicitly included my
understanding was that was an
accumulation from the estimated rice
growing for example but did that include
the the oxidation of methane it does and
it goes through the steps of rice area
rice emissions linking to rice sustain
rice concentration than the atmosphere
the same relations that are used today
yeah it implicitly assume
Lux's an increase in the concentration
about the people that are calculating
how much of the methane concentration
the atmosphere is sustained by rice
irrigation you know they work back to
the same numbers that were worked dorian
Fuller's working forward to so so that's
nothing so there is rice irrigate
irrigation doesn't explain at all maybe
explains half of the difference between
the rise and the fall that should have
happened but live stocks out there
that's a really hard one to calculate so
you don't make it this to me we could
talk about that later there's too many
things you have to take into account
there's also biomass burning which you
could think of as if you if you get the
get the debris from your crops and from
your weeding put it in pile and burn it
if there's stuff smoldering in the
bottom of the pile
that'll gild methane if it's a clean
burn fire it'll lead it'll lead it'll
yield carbon dioxide but the stuff
that's burning in this muffled
environment doesn't
so here's now here's evidence for
deforestation I already showed you some
that involves that but this has worked
from zohary and hopf in the late 1990s
here's the Fertile Crescent with the
domestication of livestock cattle goats
sheeps pig pigs sheep and pigs and crops
wheat barley peas lentils huge a huge
number of things that we eat today and
you can see that the these two colors
which bracket 8400 to 5,500 years ago
that's the time when when the crops and
the livestock shoot across Europe this
is not like saying every acre of Europe
is farmed it's just saying of
Agriculture has arrived at some density
so so this 8450 500 ruler I showed you
the co2 curve starts to rise
around 6500 so our go p-- it goes the
wrong way so this spread of agriculture
is very favorable to correlate with the
beginning of the wrong way the wrong way
co2 trend a point of interest fifty five
hundred years ago we're not even into
the Bronze Age people are taking trees
down with Flint very sharp nicely
crafted Flint axes they just girdle the
trees wait for them to die the debris
falls on the landscape they burn it
they stick which you call today double
sticks and you plant the seeds they grow
crops grow for a few years and then the
soil plays out then you have to move on
and and do it again here's from England
a compilation from the England of start
with this what is the density of c14
dated archaeological sites in in England
and you see it starts to pick up
somewhere sixty five hundred to six
thousand reaches the maximum it goes
back comes back up and then they this
compilation didn't try to map be on that
plot beyond that but that's me that's
that also consistent with that sixty
five hundred year co2 curve and
meanwhile the pollen which is there's
tricks to doing this but deciduous
woodland pollen forests basically starts
a slow fade around maybe six thousand
goes very quickly after four thousand so
basically a thousand years ago Europe is
as deforested as as it is today so this
is getting into the question of how much
deforestation happened and how much co2
release happened before the industrial
era and the answer is a lot most of it
there's been people
literature saying that for 20 or 30
years so what comes in is pastor
semi-open pasture and pasture and meadow
replacing so the anthropogenic it by
these plots the antrum anthropogenic
policy is after four thousand not quite
as early as the six thousand year co2
reversal but for those that don't like
the early anthropogenic hypothesis you
just cannot say that the Industrial
Revolution was the time when the major
deforestation happened it's very it's
clearly very early sort of question co2
fire
of carbon that would need to be released
and you know associated with the ocean
and all the rest oh yeah okay I'll get
to that or at least part of that in a
little while China has a human
enormous amount of data I don't think
and was here who I met last night but
this much more than as shown here but
this is a plot of the number of
archaeological sites in China between
8,000 and 7,000 years ago and between
5,000 and 4,000 years ago so to equal
length time slices eight thousand seven
thousand years ago you see a scattering
of sites up around the Yellow River just
a few in the Yangtze area 5,000 to 4,000
years ago the Yangtze which the yellow
which goes up like this loops back down
this is just jammed with archaeological
sites everybody was a farmer so that
this is all clearance and the clearance
between the density of sites between
here and here that's a 30 to 40 fold
increase so that's a massive amount of
deforestation after 7,000 years ago and
by 4,000 years ago and that's again
consistent with the co2 curve going in
the wrong direction now what is what's
gonna pick up after this level is here's
where the rice cultivation begins the
wet rice cultivation so all this area
and south of here and down into south of
China is going to be DeForest it as the
as the terrain goes over to rice paddies
so those are the two areas China and
Europe that was Britain but the same
pictures emerging for West Central
Europe the two areas we have a lot of
data show a lot of early deforestation
back on timescales consistent with or
anthropogenic hypothesis of now what I
think is still the criticism of the
hypothesis which still has reasonable
validity at this point it's being worked
at and knocked down is this is a
simplification but here's the co2 rise
starting about 6500 rising rather
quickly and kind of leveling off coming
into this interval if you if you follow
most people's repopulation
reconstruction they tend to use these
geometric curve there's actually
knowledge of population well if you if
you're if you're a stickler for accuracy
we only know population pretty well back
to about 500 years ago on a global basis
but you know population in China pretty
well to here and also in Europe so
that's about 40% of the of the planet
then it doesn't look quite like this but
it's it's basically in that direction so
these anything before 2000 is basically
a hindcast it's a backwards projection
using a geometric model which assumes to
put it in different terms it assumes a
doubling of population somewhere around
about every thousand years and these
models assume a constant rate of
doubling of population all the way back
from two thousand to seven or eight
eight thousand years ago and now there's
a problem with that assumption it has
the same fractional growth rate so
whether you're here on the curve or
there on the curve the fractional growth
rate of the population as as a fraction
of the population that existed is the
same all the way through for five
thousand years and that requires that
all the constraints on population growth
are flat constant for five thousand
years which is a little
yeah what are there's no constraints
people just keep reproducing and
increasing well yeah but they do it at a
certain rate which can involve
constraints and non constraints but the
rate is anyway the rate is constant it
which essentially means that biometal
implies that the environmental the
constraints are constant now
that doesn't work very well here's a
plot of Hector's farmed per person
that's actual cropland the area that a
person average person farms and by the
time you're back you're up to the modern
day it's these tiny little garden plots
in China typical agriculture in China is
a garden plot but as you go back there's
reliable population data and reliable
estimates of the of area farm collected
by the dynasty starting with the Han
Dynasty back in here and so you can
calculate area farms per person and
instead of 0.2 it's up in the zero point
zero point one eight it's up around zero
point seven so it's a not a factor of
four decrease there's some the civil
disturbance comes in with that data
point but the rest of the trends pretty
pretty this tells a consistent story
there's another this is based that one
work that a man named buck did in 1937
in Nanjing just as Nanjing was getting
into its World War two disasters and
updated by an economist in the
University of Chicago
Chao in 1986 University of Chicago Press
in Europe was a different number it's
it's based on scattered maps of area
deforested and population which again is
known
reasonably well and so this is how much
forest was cleared which is a much
larger number than how much cropland was
farmed because it includes pastures and
meadows and areas hillsides burned for
firewood and things like that but you
get the same factor of four decrease
over the last two thousand years
so people back here we're using more
land and I didn't make a point here
the problem with this plot is here's
this big rise in co2 and there's almost
no rise in population so the criticisms
how could so few people drive carbon
dioxide up so fast early on or to put it
another way if this is the cause and
this is the effect that's not a good
relationship the effect is thousands of
years ahead of the cause so part of the
reason for that offset is that the
populations back in here are not as low
as they look they're up higher by a
factor of at least four even here and it
could be as high as five or ten or more
so earlier and just give you an idea of
why that could be if you take a mature
forest and you cut it and you put crops
in as I was talking about earlier the
way people have tended to think about
this a lot of people tend and modelers
have tended to think about it is the
amount of carbon that's in the
atmosphere is the difference between
that and that that's that's your
calculation but if people are moving
every it's usually every three to four
years they think by five years later
you're getting some carbon coming back
some saplings you're getting larger and
denser saplings you're getting trees 20
or 25 years later but you're still not
back to mature forests so so the carbon
deficit or the amount that went into the
atmosphere is the
Plus this Plus this Plus this people
leave a trail a footprint of carbon
emissions half half the summation that I
just did yeah yeah yeah you'd average
out to be about half or at least the
maximum I wouldn't use an average you'd
use the sum of these they're when you
when you when you DeForest
yeah if you put a plug of co2 in the
atmosphere if the system is growing
after that then you're sequestering co2
yeah but these arrows the first plug is
the only plug and then there's a
reduction and also I there's a couple
other things that is that at least
anybody could instantaneously is 40% of
that signals going in the ocean so
whatever number you're interested in
you're only seeing an instantaneous
moment half of that if we go thousands
of years if we move out of year you're
cool birdy with the carbonate system so
it's even less so you if the trend is
going up you have to sustain those
emissions every step of the way there
always has to be more emissions in order
to have an increasing signal
signal wants to be pulled out unlike
reason this method and that you need to
have at any given moment any increasing
trend means you have an increase in
methane emissions or slugs
I had a interesting confrontation with
Paul Crutzen who knows something about
this subject at a meeting about seven or
eight years ago and he was making that
more or less the same point as your
first point and I was saying yes but
there there is this deficit of carbon
it's coming back but it's not back yet
and this is just one slice three years
from now people are gonna do this again
and again and again so there is there is
this for family or for a person there is
this continuing footprint so he didn't
like it he didn't believe me and I'm
sitting I'm sitting at breakfast the
next morning and he he comes out Nizza
he says you were right so if you think
about it it's a it's a it's an obvious
intuitive mistake to make but people
leave a footprint and the people leave
or move around so even though the court
the whole forest in this particular
region might grow back there's still a
footprint out there and it's following
your people around and so there are more
people a quick answer there's more
people through time more clearance more
footprints moving around till finally
areas become completely deforested and
there's no don't they don't go back at
all which is when you get into the last
couple of thousand years but if you hold
off I think some of what I'm going to
say will cover this so so that's part of
the answer you can't just look at the
number of people on the earth you have
to look at the fact that they're using
perhaps four times or more as much land
that their clearance footprint at any
one time as four times as large as the
population would suggest relative to
1800 where people are
farming the same plot every year and not
moving around so the person that's dealt
with this is Jed Kaplan who I think was
here right Jed Kaplan spoke earlier in
the autumn and he he he ran two sets of
models one set of models assumes that
the per capita footprint is the same low
value that it was basically here in but
that's 1700 1800 1900 and if you run
that by 2000 years ago you see that
there's hardly any deforestation well I
just showed you that Britain is mostly
deforested and China looks like it might
be mostly deforested but if you run a
model land-use simulation that assumes
larger per capita clearance or allele
and get a map that looks like that so
not just Europe and China and India but
the Inca he has Tex
there's the Fertile Crescent you get
larger splotches that are substantially
deforested 2000 years ago here's a map
from archaeologists published in the
1990s talking and this is basically this
is intense relatively intense
agriculture here and here which matches
here and here which matches so Kaplan's
model looks much more like what the
archaeological literature would suggest
but more persuasively if you use the
model this is the same kind of model
land use simulation if you use the model
that all these models allow for regrowth
of forests if it's shifting that
cultures shifting agriculture
if use them if you use the model that
assumes constant small per capita
clearances like we had in 1700 or 1800
you end up with Europe being still
mostly forested at 1800 ad this is Jed
Kaplan again somewhere in the 50% up to
80 or 90 percent says that Europe is
mostly deforested in 1800
whereas Kaplan's model with higher early
clearance gives you a Europe that's
mostly deforested well we know which one
of these maps is correct that's wrong
because Europe has been reforesting
since 1800 most of West central Europe's
been reforesting so if it was at 50 to
70% forested and it's been reforesting
Europe must be covered with forest well
its europe is mostly deforested so this
map is completely consistent with the
fact that Europe has been reforesting
since this these mapped estimates so
Kaplan must be approximately correct
there's there's very large early
deforestation and it's consistent with
land use simulation models there's three
other models that give you Europe China
India everywhere still largely reforest
it but deforested at 1800 which has
contributed to this idea that the
industrial era is the big change of
forest cover just the last hundred and
fifty years that's not true it's a it's
much much older
so I took a I did a real
back-of-the-envelope calculation and
guessed in this paper that something
like 320 billion tons of forest might
have been carbon might have been
released to the atmosphere by 1850 and I
did that by reading that literature that
told me that there was major early
deforestation and I got this number 320
along has come this paper and three
others that have made that assumption of
constant per capita deforestation and
they get numbers way smaller so this has
been a serious criticism of the
hypothesis numbers in the 50 to 70
billion tonnes instead of 320 Jed but
but these papers all implicitly assumed
small constant per capita deforestation
which is not justified because we know
that from the historical record
Kaplan gets a number that's pretty close
to two my lucky guess that would be the
equivalent if it was completely
equilibrate adminstration exchanges and
geochemical exchanges it would be about
24 parts per million co2 anomaly due to
deforestation and i said i said from the
top down view I thought it was would be
about 40 the full anomaly so this is
moving in that direction so part of the
story is that a good part of the
community has missed the fact that early
people were very wasteful in their use
of the land they used a lot of land
because they could okay once you get
squeezed onto your one hectare of land
it's not much you can do about it you
just got to figure out a way to grow
more crops use manure more manure use
rotate your crops things like that but
early on you just cut some forest farm a
bit cut
forest farm a bit so I mentioned earlier
that these models of population growth
which you called guesses I think are on
as you go back before two thousand years
ago okay I'll buy that it's all money
it's a model and bad input is bad output
so if you if you get that wrong you're
you're in trouble there's another keep
doing the part I'm thinking in the back
of my head as I talk it's good things I
would love to say so there are different
models though very common use maybe
people in the room that know much more
about it than I do
ecological models ecosystem models have
a logistic shape and they basically have
a much earlier rise relative to these
geometric models but then they tail off
and the reasoning is logistic models the
resources are more abundant initially
but then they start to get used up the
life gets tougher too so think about
fara
people in forests going in here people
going into forested river valleys with
rich soils lots of water growing crops
having terrific crops big families
moving on by the time you get into the
last few thousand years the land is
occupied yeah so you have a smaller plot
of land are you farming a hillside
you're having a farm in an arid region
so the rate of growth the fractional
rate of increase is slower there's a
paper out in penis two years ago that
shows that the fastest rates of growth
using a mitochondrial DNA in Europe
southern southeastern Asia from of south
of China and North Africa those are all
sources of agricultural innovation the
fastest rates of growth are Jeff
when agriculture gets started fractional
rates of growth you know total rates of
growth they're still going up faster
more recently but the fractional rates
of growth which puts more of the growth
back in this this kind of an interval um
it's just after agriculture arrives
which is when you have this wonderful
landscape just waiting for you to to use
so this hasn't really been incorporated
into papers very very much to to deal
with the the effect that you're going to
have but basically these this DNA
evidence and I showed you that factor of
40 increase in archaeological the
density of sites or number of sites in
China and I showed you evidence for
increasing archaeological sites in
Europe in Britain I think when this when
the population models which are totally
hypothetical when they start to get
grounded a little better you'll find
that there were more people much earlier
than we thought and if there's more
people and they're using more land
you're going to start to close that gap
or maybe completely close the gap
between between the explained that early
co2 rise there are a lot of people then
and they were growing very very fast and
they were using a lot of land I have two
more figures but I don't think they help
very much oh yeah this one might help a
little bit so here's here's what I would
call the geometric view here's that co2
rise and this is a slightly different
version McKevitt Ian Jones which is
basically it's a geometric model prior
to 2000 years ago so here's that
mismatch Jed Kaplan used a population
model that's started to incorporate some
of this logistic population data so he's
his population curve is is considerably
higher considerably earlier and he gets
that boost in in carbon emission so this
is that co2
this is cumulative carbon emissions he
gets a boost which which brings his
cumulative carbon emissions curve up up
higher Carsten lemon in that Germany is
is one of the ones doing this population
modeling and his latest model looks like
this still more people back in here and
I just all eyeballed in what the carbon
emissions curve might look like based on
on that kind of a relationship and now
and now between 7,000 and 2,000 years
ago you're starting to get a higher
increase in us almost a hint of a convex
shape it's beginning to look pretty much
like that so this debate is the least
resolved of everything I've told you
except somebody will ask me about Delft
13 co2 but I think this is the direction
that the whole thing is gonna go people
that think that weren't enough people
there were more people than you think
and they were using way more land that's
the way that that's the way the evidence
is taking us
getting in an industry that I can speak
to part of the problem
so the basic the evidence is that the
del 13 co2 signal the c-13 composition
of the co2 in the air bubbles in the ice
cores that are dated it it grows
slightly more negative over the last
seven thousand years but it's a very
very slightly more negative and if you
the people that came up with that data
from Barren Institute LC at all first
author you have to do a mass balance
calculation to figure out where that
where things are going I've jumped over
the fact that it's going more negative
of that ratio means that there's an
excess of terrestrial carbon emissions
over storage but it's only a very small
excess and if their their conversion
allowing for so there's they allowed
that that trend suggests about that much
by way of billions of tons of carbon
emitted between 7,000 and pre-industrial
they allowed something for monsoons and
they they made an estimate of the Pete's
the carbon storage stored in peat that's
not emissions that's taking out of the
atmosphere and their estimate of the
health of per genic effect that was
three point five well I'm arguing for 40
and Kaplan's beta just on one factor
argues for 24 so we're way out of
agreement well I read that paper and I I
know something about the peat literature
that that estimate is simply not just a
there there are two very impressive
compilations of the amount of carbon
buried in peat last seven thousand years
and they're about three hundred billion
tons not forty that trend is the
observation that they made I kept this
that should be the same as that it
doesn't look quite the same so assuming
we know that's still the co2 trend Delft
thirteen co2 we know that's a if that's
a reasonable estimate and it's their
estimate then where's the balance for
this well I claimed it's anthropogenic
and that number would end up being about
300 million tonnes and if that sounds
familiar
Kaplan got 340 now I've talked to
Hubertus Fisher who was a co-author and
he's in that bearing group and they have
basically admitted that the peat storage
was much larger than their estimate and
Hubertus unfortunately have lost the
email but he he said in an email he said
the del 13 co2 argument is no longer a
killer argument against the early
anthropogenic hypothesis and then he
said something to the effect of there
are too many large reservoirs which are
not well known
there's too much accommodation space it
just doesn't solve the problem so
something that I would say that
virtually the whole community thinks is
a killer argument is not by their
admission it does they still leave some
problems because that's still them that
terrestrial emissions and it doesn't
that doesn't allow for as a net that
doesn't allow for a large anthropogenic
effect but there's some some tricky
stuff here the carbon that's going in
here is more negative than the carbon
that's coming out in deforestation there
is a substantial effect if the
hypothesis is correct there's a
substantial effect on the solubility of
co2 in the ocean
quit spock and other colleagues and
myself have run general circulation
model experiments and we're estimating
about a eight parts per million effect
from co2 solubility and that doesn't
have any terrestrial carbon negative tag
I know I'm going fast if you're not used
to this but um I think I think the first
part of this argument is it's no longer
a killer argument and there are
complexities that have not been worked
out and meanwhile this bottom-up
evidence from agriculture is growing and
meanwhile the top-down evidence is not
going away so ok too many high-calorie
deals with far too much stimulating
posterior Luther cute thank you very
much
you